today still tracking that recently
approved johnson and johnson covet
vaccine good afternoon thank you for
joining us at four i'm kirstjen joyce
and i'm christian casares
it could arrive in clark county any day
now local officials expect to get 17
thousand doses of the one-shot vaccine
this week reporter kate houston spoke to
a physician about the differences
between the vaccines the southern nevada
health district hopes to have the
johnson and johnson vaccine available at
all clinics like the neighborhood
recreation center here in north las
vegas
very soon right now they're making sure
all are equipped to handle the three
vaccines
when the fda approved the johnson and
johnson vaccine many wondered how it
differs from the others available
and which they should get johnson
johnson is a viral vector vaccine and
utilizes dna
the cdc says this vaccine will put a
modified version of a different virus
such as the common cold
into a cell which will produce a
harmless component
of the covid19 virus the immune system
will recognize it doesn't belong there
and fight it off
pfizer and moderna are messenger rna
vaccines
which the cdc says teaches cells to make
that same harmless component of covid19
and fight it off local doctor michael
allsweed says there's no data to show
one vaccine will work better for certain
groups over others
it comes down to availability the choice
really isn't between the vaccine the
choice
is to get a vaccine if you can get one
or to get the covet infection which you
definitely do not want so all these
vaccines prevent the
severe form of covid which is the one
that you want to prevent
dr ozweed says the one dose johnson and
johnson vaccine may appeal more to those
with busy schedules those that travel
and those who can't make it back for a
second appointment since dna is tougher
than mrna
it can also be stored at warmer
temperatures and be left out longer
which makes it easier to distribute
kate houston 8 news now